All of us who learn languages, and myself
included, we eventually want to speak. We
want to output. Even though LingQ
emphasizes input and recognizes the
importance of input in making our brain
familiar with the language, the words, the
phrases, the pronunciation, eventually we
want to output. A good place to
start is writing, because there's no
pressure. You can look things up. You can
look up the correct ending, you know, the
correct tense to use or other
grammatical points. You can check the
word in your vocabulary section, or you
can save a bunch of words, let's say that
you've tagged, and then try to use these
words in your writing. And other members
of our community can correct these for
you in the Exchange. And then you can
import this as learning material. So, for
those of you who are prepared to
practice writing, make it a habit to
write a little bit, because it's a good
way to start yourself towards being a
more comfortable speaker of the language.